when the aliens first invaded I nearly  destroyed us they will be back there's  greatness in you enter the world needs  you you were bred for this you see  things in a way we can't you alone can  understand the enemy you will be the one  to save mankind unless we act now earth  will be annihilated we're out of time  he's not ready you're never ready go on  you're ready track them from below the  ice shoot straight stay calm here we go  never said anyone do that  we should tell him the truth why  and it's over what will be left of the  board what does it matter if there's  nothing left at all you don't try then  we will all be lost to do everything I  can to win this war you succeed you will  be remembered as a hero he's abandoning  his entire fleet he's in commanders now  stopping him now in three two  you